gang the middle class famous tour is
about to be in full effect come out and
see us it's a great way to introduce
some new people to the show so grab the
homies grab the ladies the birds the
bozos everybody and come see us yeah
guys we're going to be in hartford
albany syracuse atlanta tampa orlando
pittsburgh buffalo we ain't done yet
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago then over there to roseman and
that's just the first leg of the tour
gonna be coming so get the techies we'll
see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is are you garbage sure is
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they go to be classy or just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host nate's
foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at aunt toddy's basement
she's upstairs at the kitchen table
getting a head start on the taxes okay
we're all dependents by the way and if
anybody comes by this is actually a
pizza place
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of ru garbage
he is an international businessman took
a real bath on bitcoin this weekend bon
appetit is doing a hit piece on him next
week it's all falling apart give it up
for kj kevin james ryan hey gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you review subscribe over here on itunes
full video in 4k i might add
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true the roof cooking
baby and then obviously i'm
contractually obligated uh by the yam
family and all of its subsidiaries to
mention the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
are you garbage you can sign up you get
episodes of ayg bonus episodes of hard
feelings live streams we just hit our
last goal of 2 800. go to disney baby i
got to take the big man to disney sam
yam's dime you're gonna get stuck in
epcot
and how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good one of the
big brains behind the are you garbage
special you know them you love them give
it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
everybody what up dudes what up t-bone
i'm excited for a mickey hat a big soft
pretzel oh it's gonna be a good one big
turkey legs all around
but gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest here
with us today for the first time she is
an extremely funny extremely successful
stand-up comedian actor podcaster and
football player
you have seen her on uproarious this is
not happening gotham comedy live the
tonight show oh boy a little late with
lilly singh unprotected sets she is the
creator and the host of the amazing web
series wrist of fury she has an album
out right now called savior that you can
find on itunes spotify pandora and she
is also the co-host of the fantastic
podcast self helpless and she is on tour
right now but the big question about his
mind today is she garbage she has a
linkedin account which i think is pretty
funny
she's also out there on a coast which is
pretty nice
give it up for kelsey cook everybody hey
thanks for coming
thanks for having me linkedin i was
stunned to see that
that has not been such a stand-up
comment
really god i think i made that when i
was in college like that has not been
checked that's like a thing you do when
you're like i'm gonna get to that like
the facebook page you're like i'm gonna
get this off the ground
i don't really get the bookings rolling
in that's if you're really
procrastinating on something and you're
like just running out of apps to check
notifications on you will go look at
your linkedin and be like what's going
on here oh that's the worst one when you
make the rounds and there's nothing else
nothing happens you find yourself
scrolling through venmo
i feel like steve paid 80 bucks for what
there's no foot traffic today i don't
know what's going on must be the weather
i do that [ __ ] all the time that's but
that's the thing
i'm trying to train myself especially
now that we have more interactions on
social media i'm trying to train myself
to go to instagram check to seek to send
me messages respond post something do
the same thing on twitter and then and
then move away from it and then get the
[ __ ] out yeah get the [ __ ] out pick and
move the other day i i watched a video
like a hundred times of a woman in
russia diving into a river and then
disappearing
it's no good for the break busy day i
see paw just took a dark turn
were you jerking off to it why are you
watching a woman die 120
cause i cuz that something like that
scares me it was there was ice and she
jumped in and just disappeared and they
tried to save her but they couldn't
those russians
they they're survivors those guys they
know what they're doing i gotta get on
linkedin i gotta clean myself up um kels
what is the backstory here we know about
the foosball situation okay but start
from the starts on the beginning i'm not
even sure i know where you're from so
i'm from spokane washington okay
which feels appropriate for this show
because we were the meth capital of
america
now we're talking
i'm here
so yeah it's uh
i think it's beautiful there are some
some nicer areas
now but i mean there are still some some
rough parts
was the meth phase going on when you
were a kid i think so yeah okay but did
you visibly see it
i don't i don't particularly remember
but i remember i grew up like in the
mall you know my dad would take me to
the playground in the mall
playground in the mall yeah like just
made of weird kind of plasticky
styrofoam that's not good
absolutely across from like you know the
jc penney's or whatever yes it was in
the middle of the mall just in the
middle of the mall why would he take you
there
i think it was just so my dad is a
musician
big samara man he loves a nice love's a
nice pretzel
yeah uh my dad is a trumpet player in
the symphony okay um and then my mom was
teaching at night so he would have me
during the day and i think it was just
kind of like what can i do to entertain
this child it's free probably too yeah i
don't have to worry about the weather
i've never even heard of that i've seen
a carousel well yeah spokane special in
that way it's extra trash was there
other kids there or was it just you no
other kids there yeah bunch of people
hanging their laundry yeah
i don't think i've ever seen that or
heard about it really the hang of the
mall is tough when you're sitting out
there in one of those little benches
looking around you're like what am i
doing oh yeah you got to keep it moving
that thing was absolute hazmat you know
just kids going down with like shitty
diapers and then kids going down it was
wide open
going around yeah yeah we all have good
immune systems i think from [ __ ] ball
baths and all that [ __ ] yeah what's the
brother and sister situation so i have a
brother who is six years younger than me
okay and i have a step sister and a half
brother
and they're all younger than me that
just got half brother that got pretty
complicated pretty quick you're batting
a cycle you got blood brothers i guess
half brothers and stepbrothers i guess
you left that off the linkedin profile
broken home i'm broken
you don't want any potential employers
saying that
says here you have a half brother
um break that down for me so my parents
divorced when i was
six uh
remarried
they had a kid together my dad and
stepmom did okay and then my stepmom
already had a kid going into it
wow yeah huh kind of a brady divorced
sorry what i didn't think your parents
were divorced oh yeah yeah you didn't
read that in the times what are you
talking about i don't know i got i got a
vibe that they were that they were solid
together because i know they they played
together
right yeah foosball you can't build a
solid foundation
on a
[Laughter]
[Music]
little men out there on the field who
did you live with so you're six years
old yeah so you're six years old it's
just you your mom and your dad
um and my brother was six months old
your brother had just been born all
right so then they get divorced yeah so
full brother younger brother you look
like you wanted to say something no it's
just i get it like i'm from a very
similar situation okay yeah yeah the
half brothers would say second kid is
what absolutely puts it down the toilet
yeah well
i think having okay so
your parent you you you and you and your
brother your parents get divorced that's
all right they both get remarried then
they both start families that's okay but
the stepmom having a kid from a previous
marriage he's rolling in the back seat
yeah that that's the kid that lives in
the garage he's the one that has it like
you're making a real like you're making
a car out of junk parts that's what
you're doing how old was he when they
got together do you remember so it's
actually it's my uh sister my step
sister so she was a year younger than me
all right um and then my half brother is
like eight years younger than me okay
were you close did you guys like blend
well
i wouldn't say we didn't blend well but
i'm not particularly close with them not
necessarily with any of my siblings i've
gotten closer with my brother but when
you have a six-year age gap
it's tough but we've gotten closer as
we've gotten older yeah okay yeah and
who did you live with where did you go
um primarily with my mom but i would see
my dad as well it was kind of like a 30
minutes apart situation and you just get
shuttled back and forth how often was
the was it like weekly monthly every
other weekend um like every couple days
and who got married first that's pretty
good how quick was that process like
when they got to work they got divorced
they come in and tell you yeah and how
did they do that did they come in and
say i got to tell you something
good news bad news there was
a an affair situation my mom did not
remarry my dad married my
stepmom so that was that that was
quicker that was the very core that was
the linkedin response right there let me
tell you something and that was that
very good question mr foley let me tell
you a long swing of water she has the
pitcher for some reason yeah all right
we're in it now
let me tell you why i say it like that
now because i have gone on other
podcasts and been very open about all of
that comes back and because i don't know
i look at my parents like they're not
listening to podcasts sure but like
their co-workers do and then they come
in everybody you know water cooler and
they're like your step-daughter yeah
she's out there rubbing her mouth right
now
so nice and tommy i heard you met her at
happy hour yeah so i uh sure of course
yes
protect the innocent world so your
father
re-established himself a little bit
quicker
yes he had a little bit
he had a little bit of a head start as
we'll say
all right all right all right all right
all right oh my gosh
all right
that might not make the final film
oh that's so good he will be so upset
but yeah that's that's funny so it
didn't so you basically were at your
mom's most the time yeah okay what was
that house like was that a single-family
home or was that an apartment a condo
because it's typically
a downgrade
so unless she stays in the house you
guys were in we moved to um a different
house and it was like
sorry both both left both left that
house um
we moved to a smaller town outside of
spokane called cheney so i mean you
could like hand somebody a nickel and a
button and they're like here's your
house key like it's just yeah it was
very very cheap what's the name of the
town cheney
it sounds like a pair of pants or
something
a new pair of cheneys sounds like a hot
new weapon
like puccini's and uh thing oysters yeah
it was big like future farmers of
america
sort of a vibe there's a rodeo
very small you guys didn't have ffa in
school or anything like that yeah what's
that 4-h okay i was in 4-h
oh god oh yeah well like the boys and
girls club
no it's more horticulture
wait what so what did you have were you
studying that in school no no no i
wasn't into that but that was the vibe
of i got
a
who do you have for stables
i flunked my mule exam god damn it
[Applause]
oh my god yeah most schools in homeok
it's like a girl has to carry around a
fake baby and learn how to raise it we
had like an alpaca for a week just like
feed this [ __ ] thing
yeah so cheney was chini was interesting
but
it was just my mom um me and my brother
okay and then my dad's house was like my
stepmom and my step-sister and
half-brother so that was a bigger
household but yeah i mean it was we were
definitely the house in the neighborhood
that just always had [ __ ] in the yard
just like always yeah always toys out
always just kind of like
that house that left the christmas
lights up all year and yeah i got a lot
of curb appeal i'm picking up
trampoline in the front yard that kind
of [ __ ]
that sort of thing we had um
two dogs they were miniature american
eskimos and one of them
loved us but had a real problem with
basically anybody that wasn't us and he
got out one time and like bit the
mailman on right on the ass just like
that i feel like other neighbors were
probably not super stoked on sure us all
the time yeah yeah yeah
yeah and what was your mind your dog
bites somebody especially the male
that's like kind of like that's like of
a comic book yeah that's usually you got
to put it down that's a whole bunch i
know he he escaped through uh through
being put down he did not
if anybody asked i was here
i was home with my kids all night what
the [ __ ] are you talking about what was
your mom doing for work at the time so
my mom was actually my high school
french teacher oh my god this i thought
you were like this
yeah this is way more dicey than i
anticipated i thought you were a family
of learned champions yeah
[Laughter]
i honestly did i pictured it i pictured
like your parents both looking like
german skiers or something i kind of
pictured that you have a swedish vibe
going yeah yeah is that your dad
everybody's wearing wooden shoes
i pictured your dad like tall
with like glasses but built and like him
and your mom and they and they were
always like they're actually
no no very nerdy i mean my dad is my dad
is it not only was he like a pro
foosball player but he
is currently a slam poetry champion like
a national slam poetry champion and was
a league yes and was an international
yo-yo man
trumpet player for a living so just
weird clown
vibe in my home
monetize a hobby i'll tell you that
somebody get them some devil sticks
[ __ ] paper airplane champ of the
midwest
holy [ __ ]
yeah okay okay your mom was your french
teacher yeah your mom speaks french yes
french
a lot of guessing a lot of shooting in
the dark but it's chi chi's washington
no one cares just no one's ever going to
france she's watching
it's just german but nobody knew the
difference yeah
just plays chocolate every day for
200 days straight
um
watch moulin rouge 15 times
yeah my mom so she is this weird blend
where she my mom is in the hall of fame
for foosball which is like the trashiest
sentence i could have wild
also i always thought it was foosball
you say foose i say you can say either
okay you can say either but so that is
over here
i heard you say it on something the
other day i think with big j and yeah
and i was just like oh i'm an idiot i've
been pronouncing i'm wrong this whole
time no you can do either okay so that i
do feel like is
to conquer something at that level is so
cool
i know i agree i just didn't expect just
to conquer something like she climbed
everest
but i do agree we were talking about it
outside listen mastering a skill is is
crazy it doesn't matter what it is okay
that's why i said we're not we're not
immediately jumping at a gun right like
everybody else like oh foosball you're
trash it is an international sport to
accomplish something like that is
amazing yeah as long as it's not like
darts or something like that you don't
know what it is all rights get no
respect they get no respect i mean but
i'm sure that these tournaments and all
that stuff were at like legitimate play
you weren't all doing these at like a
shonies or something like that it wasn't
in the game room of a [ __ ] howard
johnson they were at like legitimate
like you know uh
uh hotels and stuff like that i would
assume right most of them it kind of
depends on the city sometimes it does
get a little bit more garbage depending
on where it is but um so not like
any of these tournaments ever taking
place at a restaurant
where they serve food yeah i mean also
how naive of you to think they're
rolling out the red carpet for the
foosball i thought it would be like the
convention center or something like that
sometimes but
there's one in portland every year that
is really fun to plan but it it is held
in a bar it's like the portland state
championships and so it's the back room
of a bar and there are
usually i think six seven tables and
they're able to run the tournament off
that but if you go to the hall of fame
tournament in vegas that is held in one
of you know it was in like um the
flamingo
there you go yeah and then it's in one
of the ballrooms there's not appetizer
samplers going around no yeah there's a
ballroom there are usually a hundred
tables
in there so that those are the bigger
tournaments there's a wide range so i'm
just going to ask you this about it yeah
when they were competing
so they would like take you to these
events before you played as a child so
you would be in portland at that
restaurant on a saturday afternoon
watching a foosball
i don't know i'd go back to the
playground at the mall yeah that's tough
no i loved it because i would play i
mean they had me playing when i was
two years old and could stand on a stool
to see the top of the table like they've
had me playing my whole life so i would
go compete in the kids events and uh
yeah i don't have any trophies i have
all my trophies
so most of them are being used for the
rissa fury set right okay okay you guys
would love them they are covered in
flames like as any good sure it's a very
guy fiery vibe i mean just lots of
flames on the trophies everybody has
sunglasses on top of the trophies
it's like a foosball that's with like a
smiley face and sunglasses so garbage
but uh yeah that's i i love all my
trophies okay all right all right but do
you have any displayed in your in your
home i do
outside for like out in the living room
wow
wow uh i have a quick one
is there a photograph of either of your
parents holding a giant check
i think so yeah there is one of my mom
somewhere have you ever received a giant
check
i haven't gotten a giant check i'm
trying to think what this is the most i
made are you sure these are
bunch of dirty ones what are you talking
about it's not the masters
jesus christ holding the big mozzarella
stick you're getting you're getting a
gift card to whatever the bar was oh all
right take your turn in the claw machine
and beat it
you get 20 credits on a jam box
holy this is so accurate kip let's talk
about butcher box baby butcher butcher
butcher box i got a freezer full of meat
right now gang if you like top quality
meat sign up for butcher box they send
it right to your door's subscription no
worry no muss absolutely fantastic
quality yes better taste more ethical
more sustainable the whole nine yards
they take the guesswork out of finding
that high quality meat we said it once
you said it 100 times they sent us about
57 000 pounds of meat chicken porks got
wild sockeye salmon that's the good
stuff the good old stuff and the ground
beef is unbelievable uh it's super
convenient they send them right to you
uh there's no antibiotics no added
hormones each boxing contains 8 to 14
pounds of meat depending on the box you
choose that's enough for 24 individual
meals packed fresh shipped frozen for
convenience so you never
so you can save time your next grocery
trip this is your chance to never have
to shop for ground beef again that's
right butcher box is giving new members
free ground beef for life again i don't
even know how they're doing this jesus
uh sign up at butcherbox.com ayg get two
pounds of ground beef free in every
order for the life of your membership
log on to butcherbox.com ayg to claim
this deal do it yeah do it camp let's
talk about them athletic greens baby
ag-1 you mean a-g-1 that's what we call
it over by the over by the db presses
yeah over there at the gym uh-huh
absolutely i can't say it enough now
listen i've had some uh issues with my
gut
okay though you're gonna make fun of me
i never but the lining of my gut like my
gut health my immunity all that kind of
stuff this knocks everything out right
out of the ballpark i have one one shake
a day i have it in the morning and when
i go to the gym when i do my gym days i
bring that with me and i have that
throughout the workout and i'm telling
you it sustains me yeah it's like a
super duper multivitamin fantastic it's
lifestyle friendly whether you uh keto
paleo vegan dairy free gluten free the
whole nine yards contains less than one
gram of sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals
or artificial anything while still
tasting good
um
uh athletic greens is climate neutral
certified company there you go yeah take
that put that in the bank there you go
uh athletic greens has over seven
thousand five-star reviews recommended
by professional athletes everybody's
using it every month using it right now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition especially heading into flu
and cold season it's just one scoop in
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills supplements
you're not looking like an idiot
easy peasy but they said they send you
the thing the container to shake it up
in which is a cool little container the
container that you stored in is this
nice metal container sure and what i got
they sent us some on the go packets too
so if you got to put it in a bottle of
water you can throw in a bottle of water
and you're out the door easy peasy out
the door athletic greens are going to
give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com garbage again that's
athleticgreens.com garbage take
ownership of your health and pick up
your ultimate daily nutritional
insurance do it now back to that show
yeah
they do have the big checks but they are
for if you win open singles or open
doubles so the main events if you win
those and you're walking away with
thousands of dollars you will get a big
check so by the time
uh so you're sick so about the time of
the divorce had this started to teeter
off
or was were you starting to do this more
and more at six um like was your mom's
career winding i can't really said that
was your mom's career winding down
so because she taught full-time she was
my high school's french and german
teacher oh wow she has her master's in
french literature she's very like the
fact that she has all that all right
here we go she is learning now where did
she go to school
so she went to um
university of oregon for her master's
okay all right university of oregon for
her master's okay she speaks french she
speaks german
yeah that's pretty good yeah she's
amazing you speak any any other
languages so french but not fluently i
used to speak it a little bit better but
i
i minored it in it in college and then
really stopped where'd you go to college
um i did my freshman year at willamette
university which is a small
uh private one in oregon and then
felt just like it was not enough of a
college experience it just felt like
high school kind of so i transferred to
washington state university for the rest
of the time and just destroyed my liver
yeah shout out to it but the i'm sorry
the small school
wasn't for academic purposes that you
had to go there before you could
transfer anything right no i um i got a
lot of scholarships to that university
and it kind of made sense or why what
are we talking about like yeah well
there are other youtubers for academics
oh okay yeah all right but um i don't
know it seemed like a good fit at the
time i was also kind of my high school
boyfriend and i were kind of following
each other which is always a giant
mistake we broke up within like six
months sure of course
uh but at the time it felt like that's
what i wanted to do was to go
somewhere that was
a little bit out of my comfort zone and
it was a great school i would be a
smarter person if i had stayed i would
know way more than i did by going to wsu
but sure wouldn't make a beer funnel
though
goddamn right what uh what'd you get on
your sats
that's a big one on the show
[ __ ]
was it still out of 1600 then probably
yeah you think you're like my age how
old are you how do you not know 32. yeah
so oh it might have just changed
because it went from 1600 to 24. right
yeah i took it at 16 but then it went
back to 1600. what'd you get i remember
i i can't remember that one but i
remember for the act isn't 21 the
highest score i think i got a 19 on that
one really what was your gpa
i graduated like 12th highest in my
class how many kids were in the class
yeah i think that 300 or something
that's pretty good pretty good
i didn't realize you were gonna there's
so many i was not expected to talk about
this in here like lisa simpson
yeah
act is out of 36.
and you got a 19
no
it was
i swear it was out of 21. they would
have changed that too when they changed
or who knows what they do out there in
this backwoods time whatever it was it
was like a few points under the top okay
but so you're smart
yeah yeah sure
i'm not holding it against you i'm also
very i'm also a learned man
i guess i mean it's all relative but
there's a [ __ ] ton of people in the
world canadians you're smart i guess
yeah i don't know i i would say i'm
telling you you're smart
if you got an any academic money to go
to a college you're doing all right but
i think there's so many there are so
many comedians who are brilliant on
stage and are so fast but maybe didn't
do that well in school yeah i'm sitting
next to him i mean he's one of those
it's one of the quickest guys i've ever
seen in my life standardized tester rig
what do you want from me
i had add i didn't diagnose until
college
and then took all of his ritalin in one
day yeah
shout out to new year's eve
yeah they prescribed me ritalin and it
was right at the break and we went up to
penn state for new year's eve and i had
it with me in my shaving kit like i'm
supposed to
i came back and there was none of it and
they were like yeah you're not getting
that everything did the barbasol too
one and done with this guy yeah um
okay all right all right all right all
right all right all right this one i
gotta be honest there's another one i
was like i said i thought you were more
whole like i didn't realize there was uh
some dirt under the fingernails yeah did
you get any trouble at college at
washington state no i will say i'm a
pretty i'm a pretty big square when it
comes to that stuff i'm very afraid of
breaking rules or whatever when i was
telling you about that playground in the
mall i used to go up to boys that were
far older than me much bigger and if
they were climbing up the slide i would
go up to them and be like you can't do
that like my dad would catch me when i
was like
over here dude
real buzz kill got an earpiece a real
bummer
real bummer at slumber parties but you
were boozing at school i was boozing
pretty hard at school yeah okay
still booze yes okay but i didn't start
i did get a fake id that was probably
the most likely so i could vote
[Laughter]
registered democrat
there was a seminar i really wanted to
give oh my god uh that was probably the
first thing i ever did that felt like
ooh this is
like i could get in trouble if yeah
that's pretty bad yeah that's tiny but
it's not that bad i never had a fake id
really
i used my brothers that's a fake idea
idiot that's not you i had one made
really yeah spent a hundred bugs yeah
what state was it texas wow
memorized i was a new york man
i had to have my mom take the picture of
me
because i needed a picture taken in
front of a white background did she know
what it was for
she did yeah well she's like i'm like
hey i just came home with a i was trying
to do this but i couldn't get like you
have a big texas mustache
it's a selfie
oh my god
oh no no she was like what are you i'm
like you got to take my picture from the
white background she's like why i'm like
we're making a powerpoint from school or
something she's like no you're not oh my
god whatever what were the vacations
like as a kid
let's say post-divorce
so well hold on i'm sorry you might ask
how long did it take your mom to get
remarried she didn't she never did okay
so it was okay so that was it was always
her house and that was it yeah all right
um
a lot of our vacations after the divorce
had to do with foosball like it would be
a on both sides no my dad stopped
competing um
we would do weird family road trips but
like that's what we wanted where
we're gonna see like you know a big
potato or a yoyo hall of fame it would
be like to visit
my great grandma and she would
sometimes give us tuna sandwiches that
like we were pretty sure she like to as
she got older we were like i think she
opened can of cat food and didn't
realize it like [ __ ] like that what are
you talking about would you eat it
i remember eating and being like this
isn't tuna
like weird
not good oh my god i'm not gonna be able
to sleep tonight or just a tuna sandwich
where she wouldn't drain it would just
be so wet just like sopping wet tuna
listen i think tuna we should stop with
the tuna yeah knock it off go to snakes
[ __ ]
yeah oh god you're eating cat food
ah you should have lost literally
possible it's
i was young but i do remember thinking
this seems like captain hook yeah yeah
obviously i would do my favorite snack
growing up was wonder bread with just
mayo on it
that was your favorite snack that's my
favorite tis now
still going strong i wanted to ask you
about the mayonnaise situation he
literally does have mayo written down
i'm not lying he just says mayo mayo was
it was it hellman's or maybe dukes out
there or was it miracle whip
it was a miracle whip okay hellman's
nice yeah yeah yeah so you think miracle
is gross yes
okay mom speaks two languages mom speaks
two languages
um
did you make your lunch growing up or
did you buy it at school
my mom
uh
bless her she would try to make me good
luck like pack me a good life right
she i would open my lunch box this would
probably be like third fourth grade i'd
look at my lunch box compared to other
kids and other kids would have like a
sandwich and an apple and stuff like
that i would have like fruit snacks
fruit gushers
fruit roll-up
hershey's bar
apple and then maybe like a bagel or
something
and i would get home and i would be like
i feel like i'm supposed to have other
stuff in here like i feel like this
isn't good even at that age i was
feeling like this is gonna be bad for me
later really and she was like
it's fruit snacks it has it's fruit that
was the 90s though for sure it's fruit
juice gushers we knew better they're i
mean they were i would get i'd get an
occasional lunchable
i i [ __ ] with lunchables okay but
after oh yeah that cold that cold pizza
why did i do that i was never a fan oh
ask them to heat it up for you at least
no just
get access to the cafeteria microwave
like a psychopath yeah
um did you would you drive to high
school with your mom
or like would you take the bus or did
you drive we lived really like within
walking distance
you walked to school you were a walker i
could walk once i got my driver's
license i would drive not a good look
walking to school no living too close to
the high school ain't great either yeah
that's bad it's weird
yeah man i see a lot of school buses
driving by what was the first car
i had a chevy cavalier
[Music]
not used obviously my mom gave it to me
i will say that was like a nice
privilege thing she's like you can have
this i'm gonna get a new car what color
was it
tan ooh did you put any aftermarket
effects into it
did you do anything to it
naws no
she slowed it down i don't want to be
tempted to go over the speed limit put a
governor on it
can you can you lower the horsepower on
this thing yeah no i didn't have more
rear view mirrors
put in extra headlights okay okay okay
um
hmm couple of cues here okay
you drink
yes if you go to a restaurant
and you order a bottle of wine you don't
finish it will you take it home
so i am deathly allergic to wine so i
can't drink wine what are you allergic
to grapes sulfites sulfites
that's weird i don't even i don't even
know they were in there
it sounds like they're in a bunch of
stuff too
not just wine
that sounds like a star trek alien
[Laughter]
sulfites
are you allergic to anything else so
many things yeah i don't think it just
starts and stops it's still fights
give us the rundown latex
really so that's my the whole story i
did on this is not happening on comedy
central is about uh finding out i was
allergic to latex because i tried the
heat of the moment well worse i the
first time i tried masturbating i used
this like manicure tool thing that was
made of rubber latex and um i had to go
to the hospital
that's why you're gonna say you put on
gloves or something yikes this broke
can't catch a breakout how old for you
uh like thirty-two
just last night
how old were you
it was a high school it's like about
halfway through high school and this is
during the day is this at night this was
i came home from school my mom hadn't
come home yet uh-huh
you're pretty strange
all my all my friends had lost their
virginity and i hadn't yet and i just
it's that big fomo feeling in high
school where you feel left out of the
conversation and i just wanted to know
what it felt like so that i could kind
of get what they were talking about so i
this manicure tool it was shaped like a
dick there's no way these people put
this out there and didn't think it's
going to go in holes like it's it was
tapered it was this whole thing
and so i just painted it
[Laughter]
ridiculous
i think it was more likely you were
doing your nails with a dildo
okay
so it's after school yeah so you do your
thing how quick does the reaction set in
immediately and how bad is the reaction
everything's swelled shut down shut down
there yeah what are you what about like
blowing it
get this thing started
a little foreplay yeah
wait i heard they like this yeah what
does it burn like is he getting hives
and stuff like that are you going into
like what's it shock no i didn't go into
anaphylactic shock but
step what do you what do you go to your
mom yeah so she had come home at that
point
and you're freaking out do you tell her
absolutely freaking out i looked at it
with a mirror and the hole was gone
my life flashed before my eyes this was
like my first ever
foray into
sex anything and this is the first
of course of course
and this is what happened i was
making me nervous you guys are gonna
like hide your pens and hide the water
balls you're like we can't trust her
with anything uh so yeah i had to go
tell
my mom i had nothing prepared i just it
was a lot of like i would have been like
i fell on the manicure thing in my
underwear but i couldn't yeah i couldn't
it was like i was just using asl like i
was just doing like a lot of hand
motions to try to describe what i did
because it was so embarrassing to
actually hold on at the time you don't
know
that it's a that it's an allergic
reaction
i told you
you dumb [ __ ]
all right yeah so you tell your mom hey
we got to go to the emergency room yeah
and uh so she took me and they looked
and it was this whole [ __ ]
cheney's this tiny town so i went to the
family doctor
this like
christian barbershop
yeah he called volunteer firemen to show
up with the jaws of life
holy [ __ ] so you went to it didn't even
go to like an er you went to a doctor it
was like the emergency walk-in clinic
okay and um
it was uh yeah my
this man
sweet man in his 60s very christian oh
my god very like steve from blue's clues
energy just what do we have here
is that a closed vagina
where's the hole on this thing
someone's been into the
the pedicure equipment again i see
all right
yikes
damn
so
you know you guys asked about alex did
you did you have to explain did you have
to because i mean you don't really have
to say hey it doesn't matter how we got
here yeah we're here yeah we're here
we're here you have to confess yeah
because nobody
i i got there and i had basically a
panic attack because the nurse was like
my little brother's best friend's mom
and i just was
i was like everybody in my town is going
to find out about this and so as i was
trying to explain it to her
story control
rule number one
[Music]
get your hands on it first first thing i
want to say is i'm suing that company
all right
before we get into this we're getting
the hound why
listen
jesus yeah so i was hyperventilating i
think they gave me like a valium
okay now you're on drugs i'm on drugs
and um
i just calmly
explained to him what we're doing what
happened and i couldn't have picked a
worse
object because nobody
he was like you have to bring it with
you did you no oh my god oh it's in a
bag
you're on exhibit a god um
is he in the courtroom today that's him
right there
yeah nobody
knew what a manicure tool was so i would
tell them and then they'd be like
oh yeah we still we don't know because
they were trying to figure out what was
wrong with you yeah okay you can't just
look at somebody just learned the latex
and say that's a latex allergy well i
didn't bring it in so they didn't know
they didn't know anything you're just
flying blind here they just thought it i
yeah
made it angry like i just upset it
it was uh yeah so what else what are
their allergies
when you find out how i found that i was
allergic to peanuts you're not gonna
believe it
what else are you allergic to peanuts of
course
so i was shoving them on my hands
so i get back from third grade
on a southwest flight pop into the
bathroom i gotta give you a bag of
peanuts on an airplane
it's
um
yeah peanuts
uh
just a bunch of random [ __ ] okay yeah
yeah but you're
we went so far off that you were asking
about wine
yeah is there like an equivalent
question well what you're involving
drink usually cheetos and soda nice
classy but i've been doing tequila more
lately
tequila soda okay that's cool yeah you
have a brand for tequila you casamigo's
gal yeah shout out to clooney hell yeah
yeah kid's all right
kid does our parents drink yes what do
they drink
my dad also loves tequila and bourbon
my mom
loves a corona
all right checks out
yeah
that's too shabby
was any movies ever filmed in your
hometown um
claim to fame you know benny and june
very old johnny depp yep of course that
was in spokane
all right i'm trying to think what else
there was like a christian slater cuba
gooding jr movie that i was supposed to
be the uh the weather woman in
the news reporter no this was when i was
in college and i got the role and they
took it from me because the news station
that they were going to use to film it
out they're like if you're going to use
our station you have to use our anchor
damn robbed me of that goddamn imdb
hardball hollywood small town politics
jesus but i think that's mostly it no
athletes from your from your hometown
other than your mom and dad
um john stockton
he's in the newsroom he is in the news
recently we're not super proud of him
right now
god damn it john stockton
get your [ __ ] together pull back from
fox news a little bit johnny huh yeah oh
stockton
but yeah i mean so we have gonzaga which
is like our big right right right okay a
big thing um anyone in your family smoke
a pipe
no okay
um growing up did you get any mail for
anybody in your house that didn't live
there
cousins or anything like that anybody
registered to your address no for any
reason no what about now no
okay
and you guys have ponytails in your
family
not in my family
but
all these questions apply to foosball
just a players of all of this not a full
set of teeth in the house you know
in your tournament in your opinion
how many pringles
is it acceptable to eat at the same time
in one bite how many pringles in one
bite and one bite how many pringles
because nobody really does just one
pringle at a time
i could do like four or five four or
five
i would say the classy answer would be
three anything more than that the crumbs
become an issue very close crackling
very messy the classy answer is two
two is the limit of pringles that one
should have in their mouth try it we do
have pringles right there they are so
old
those are over a year old do not they
are we bought them the day we got the
studio
i don't think i would
go bad
pringles go bad okay now we're doing
science now i'm in
toby get my lab coat
i haven't had a pringle in years but i
think like back in the day
i would i would maybe do four if i
wanted to i think i would mostly do one
do you run a tight ship eating wise
you're in good you're you're healthy in
good shape do you think yeah yeah i
think i'm kind of forced to because of
the allergies and weird dietary [ __ ]
it's like
there's not much left what about fast
food to eat fast food ever i love in and
out
burgers
but i can't like
i don't do talk i mean taco bell is just
i have ibs it'd be an instant you have
ibs too
jesus christ lemon over here
send this one back to the factory worse
than the camry holy [ __ ]
god damn
shitload of allergies and ibs yup yikes
um
have you ever ridden a mechanical bull
yes
did i did i ride one at saddle ranch
that's sad what's saddle ranch it's that
super touristy bar on sunset strip in la
uh
did i
i think i haven't seen you can do it
that's true
i think i think i have once okay
growing up
got to eat with your family
was there a popular dish in the town
that everybody got like you would go to
like luke's and everybody got the lemon
chicken or something like that
not really we didn't have a ton of
restaurants in cheney would you go out
to dinner with your mom or your dad's
family yeah we would but it was i mean
there was like red robin and okay stuff
like that all right uh
my stepmom would make a d i just wonder
if this is
only in our area have you guys heard of
eggs on a goldenrod
this is this is what i'm looking for
yeah
this is what we're looking at here we go
golden rod
eggs i like goldenrod
uh four hard cooked eggs two tablespoons
butter
all right let's see
are those mashed potatoes i don't know
what it is
so what is it so
you toast bread
and then you make this creamy sauce that
has
the egg whites in it but like
hard-boiled egg whites and then you take
the yolks out and almost shred them
and you put them on top
i know it sounds really it's so [ __ ]
good but it's it looks great yeah it's
great it looks all right it is a little
white
if it was potatoes i could see but
martha stewart has her own a golden rod
recipe and she's classy
yeah
mice i mean it's the jail time it's like
a deviled egg it's a white it's kind of
like a deviled egg yes deconstructed
dinner dish
deconstructed's pretty good that's true
sure we had four kids in that household
with my dad and stepmom so they were and
they were both
on a budget so that's a very
cost-effective
dish it's like bread and eggs yeah would
that be breakfast or would that be
dinner
all of the above really yeah mm-hmm
yeah
wowzer wowser wowser
what was the local pizza place where
would you guys get your pizza from on
friday nights oh boy rose's pizza which
was also a bowling alley
nice
best ranch
best ranch best ranch
having the having a best ranch place
mm-hmm okay
yeah real thick
great
mayoe ranch homemade best yes made it
right there in the bowling alley
right there probably put some of that
spray from the shoes
that was a secret ingredient put a
little lacquer
[Laughter]
do you chew ice
no really
okay interesting
would you say the credit score is
i have actually really good credit score
really good credit yeah almost 800. whoa
really
credit cards
about how many you got
i think maybe like eight what eight
credit cards yeah uh running balances or
no
some of so it's like nordstrom where
maybe i'll buy something a few times a
year on it but then there are a couple
that i use primarily and i just
nordstrom rack
what about you got an amex
nice i just got that though really
that's new because now with touring more
everybody's like you gotta do delta yeah
delta ceramics is the way to go yeah so
that's what i'm doing now
okay
but capital one card yes what's the
limit
fifteen
thousand dollars yeah this girl's rich
[ __ ]
you could buy all the eggs golden rods
you want
holy cow 15 grand that's pretty good god
damn
the richest person i've ever met in my
life
you have a [ __ ] comic i'm just like
you guys
i just this i've been doing comedy for
12 years getting an agent this past year
and getting a tour set up it's the first
time that i've ever financially been
like oh oh i am okay i don't have a gun
to your head of course right yeah but
like i'm not i don't know yeah of course
foosball family don't come from money
for the love of god
i think i'd be doing this [ __ ] if i came
for money
foosball royalty yeah
i'm just like everybody else folks
that's not happening
okay okay not one of those bumper poles
yeah was there was there beef with like
ping pong players and [ __ ] do foosball
players look down on other
table games after like a nice match
they're hanging around having beers
being like you see those [ __ ]
whatevers and have you ever gone to
europe to play
i haven't gone to europe to play but my
mom and my brother have because there
were brothers in it too
that's worse than everybody ordering the
same thing at the restaurant you're all
playing foosball he's got a champion
what do you expect
yeah
he doesn't have a choice this game he
was born into royalty
if he could he'd [ __ ] throw it all
away and work at his dollars who else
plays
um just me my brother and my mom just
everybody just everybody just my entire
family the step sister nothing like that
your brother plays and he's six he's in
his prime right yeah he doesn't go
compete anymore but he played in the
world cup in the junior division he was
really good i mean he's still really
good but yeah
yeah damn what else does he do what does
he do now he just works in finance he's
like the one and one person in our
family that was like i'm not doing the
circus life okay and the rest of us did
yeah is he still is he out there in
spokane he's in idaho
idaho financial capital the
there is a lot of stuff actually in
idaho yeah a lot of corporates
no buffets in
nebraska
i know this
coeur d'alene's got a lot of money
uh coeur d'alene is a city in idaho oh
okay yeah but
who's cordelia i thought it was some
european foosball
i mean that's quarterly yeah he did
pretty well back in the day he's got
like a lot of endorsement money golden
hair yeah
yeah so that's my brother okay hey huh
hmm
uh anyone in your family ever rented a
storage unit
oh lord oh god really when you were a
kid
no but in more recent years my mom is
definitely a big hoarder she's just from
i think it's our parents generation that
just sure they they love to hold on to
is there more than one unit love a vhs
no one but it is jam-packed yeah
i'll go ahead no please i'm sorry oh
she's kept every piece of school work
i've ever done
like just one of those things which is
very sweet but unnecessary no it was
right when we moved to the philadelphia
area moved into a smaller house
and
i remember one saturday my dad we went
to look at one because my dad was
thinking about getting one and i
remember i knew then i was probably like
11 or 12 and i started bawling crying
because i i was like we're losing our
house we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to live in here yeah dude i didn't
like it
going there when you were a kid that's
at the gate and you drive around and
yeah
i i even worse remember uh
when that show what was it storage
hunters oh storage walls
wars top shelf programming i may or may
not have attended uh an auction
well in my defense it was right across
from my office and they were out there
hooting and hollering you know hippies
betting heavy
but he saw that weed whacker his eyes
burst saw an artificial christmas tree
and i was just like maybe i'll go just
see what it's uh that's that show was
booming that's just trash cause first of
all none of those numbers are back yep
those [ __ ] just [ __ ] make
everything in there he's like i got a
bottle of water i got 25 bucks for that
[ __ ] boom and they're adding [ __ ] up
somebody give me an accountant here
i know campbell's just on a smoke break
looking to drive the price up that's
kind of what i was doing i was out there
smoking
and they'd be right there yeah okay 650
250. let me just you know i kept getting
closer and closer to i was right at the
fence oh my god
and i did pop in i didn't you know
obviously they have the funds on me
not ready i couldn't partake
i'm gonna run out to the car and write
you guys a check real quick
yeah gonna splurge on that leg lamp
hey that's a collector's eye
don't you speak ill
like a set of hubcaps in there
you know what else is in my mom's store
you know i just remembered are all of
the beanie babies
oh she still has hundreds did you guys
watch the beanie mania documentary
no
i lived it
absolutely i was in it
did it
rock your family financially no we never
i never really bought i never really
bought into them but they were like it
was the hottest thing for like a [ __ ]
two year or whatever it was did it be
because especially if you go back and
watch that documentary they would
release beanie babies in these very
small quantities and then it would drive
the price up for other people and make
it like oh these are going to be worth
so much someday so my mom was spending
like
hundreds of dollars sometimes on being
it just brainwashed you guys would go
out and go out and look for beanie
babies yeah and then when they went to
mcdonald's and they were like the teeny
beanies the mcdonald's happy meal toys
we would just eat at mcdonald's over and
over that week to collect all of them
and then they'd become christmas
ornaments like that is pretty bad
happy meal toys on the tree this is a
sick twisted tail
we had i had a beanie baby cookbook
do you remember how people just beat the
baby baby
people were learning how to make as much
money as they could with every off shoot
there were beanie baby calendars
whatever everything so some woman in the
midwest probably named like trish or
tabitha just made the beanie baby
cookbook which were
just like polaroid photos poorly taken
photos of dishes with a beanie baby just
like plopped up next to the plate mac
and cheese or whatever
and i we had all that [ __ ] yikes yeah
and now it's in the garage so none of
those are worth anything now no because
i missed that whole crate yeah no when i
was a kid
when i was a kid it was cabbage patch
kids okay yeah that was big too but they
viewed as collect they were just viewed
as like a hot gift yeah kids just wanted
them these were viewed as like
[ __ ] cash out the 401k absolutely
there's a guy in the documentary that's
like i'm
gonna be putting my kids through college
with this in 20 years and i just can't
wait i mean it was genuinely what people
thought was going to happen was she big
into the state quarters as well did she
go after the quarters absolutely hanging
up on my mom's bedroom wall was the map
full full yeah hanging up on her bedroom
wall wall map quarters in each state yep
it's wild she didn't get remarried
my mom's the best
of course she sounds like a sweet woman
she's the best yeah i love it
yeah jesus beanie babies
how are you at beer pong does the
foosball translated all that the
hand-eye coordination yeah cause i've
seen videos of you playing it's bananas
thank you it's like it's it's like
[ __ ] terminator style
thanks i'm okay at beer pong i would not
say i'm
like great at it but
if you
that hand-eye coordination i think does
translate to a lot of things so
yeah football's just very specific we
can't have where we come from that's the
past what about now it's i want to know
all right yeah the apartment now um
what's a sleeping situation do you sleep
with a fan directly on you
no how many pillows or how many pillows
are on the bed and how many pillows do
you use at night there are four pillows
on the bed i use one
one pillow
just under your head that's it better
for your neck
do you sleep on your back
i have been trying to train myself to
sleep on my back but i still wake up on
my side okay and you don't use the
pillow between your legs or holding one
or anything no but i've i just started
seeing a chiropractor and she said that
i should be doing the pillow between the
legs or the pillow underneath your knees
if you're on your back to try to keep
your hips in alignment that's pretty
classy what size bed you got king or
queen queen
not bad not bad not bad
okay
uh do you have a working printer at the
apartment no i don't know i don't
know an answering machine what year is
it do you have a landline what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah none of that okay what's the stove
situation electric or gas electric
electric stove with the with the wires
the coils
full-size fridge
okay
okay
do you buy scented trash bags
yes do you have a printer
uh yes not bad
which one is it the old one the picture
or the thing that goes in and out of the
fridge like the uh
it's uh well i guess you know i used to
have the brita but now it's the fridge
has the
the filter
wait what do you mean the fridge has a
filter your refrigerator has ice and
thing yeah okay okay i feel like
everybody outside new york hat only new
yorkers don't have that really yeah it's
not a new york thing for some reason
do you pee in the shower yes you do i
have a whole bid on this i don't think
we've ever asked a female that i didn't
know they could to be honest with you
that just blew my [ __ ] mind did you
hear how fast i answered that like i was
on [ __ ] family feud i buzzed in i was
like yes that's a whole a whole bit i do
on stage yeah brush your teeth in the
shower no
too busy being too busy yeah
you got to be focused
have you ever been ghost hunting
no okay do you floss every day yes
every day
she's pretty classy you still have any
of your baby teeth no okay any wisdom
teeth no
have you or any member of your family
ever been attacked by a wild animal
any circumstances
camping
[Laughter]
[Music]
no
no i don't think so did you guys ever
bring an animal from outside into the
house and try to raise it my mom is a
big raccoon lady oh my god
so what does that even mean
she just
has a big heart she just loves to hate
me i have told me i come from possum
people
a big raccoon lady
they just
she thinks they're cute she thinks
they're cute okay they are you bring
them in the house no thank god but
she'll get
she's gotten very close to them in
proximity she puts dry cat food out i
thought you meant emotionally it's vape
bonded she has names for them um but
yeah she puts out cat food she just it
breaks her heart to think of them
getting either starving in the winter or
getting trapped and taken so she just
she feeds them and she loves them but
i've told her i was like you
they're supposed to be dangerous yeah
and laborers can't like that they
absolutely do not
i mean they have rabies or yep they
don't starve their animals they're out
there and they're mean i know
i know
i'm just telling you the information
i'm putting it in your hands
make your decisions do you think she
likes them because they're the animal
most likely to play foosball
the only animal that can play foosball
opposable thumbs
she's out and out of goalie she needs to
start training
i think i just got a couple more
uh
did you ever write your name in wet
cement
no okay
these questions you guys are so good
do you use the instant transfer on venmo
i'm gonna say no
no i do standard yeah i'd imagine you're
pretty responsible she's conservative
yeah
that's i mean that fifteen thousand
dollar [ __ ] that's how you get it you
don't have to come for money to have a
big credit limit you're just
conservative yeah yeah was there ever a
you know the first big somewhat payday
in comedy
mm-hmm
okay
and did you go out and buy something
real stupid um
it's actually you know what the the one
that i'm most excited about is coming up
it's one of the gigs i have and that one
i feel like i've preemptively spent it
spent a little bit of it on um like uh
skincare laser facial stuff
okay yeah you're gonna go get some
treatment done yeah it's i've already
had i'm like halfway through it but it
just makes your skin
better how more even how how much is the
treatment do you feel comfortable saying
i mean
i don't know if you're over over 5 000
no less less than that okay over two
around
it's not that bad yeah how many
treatments do you get out of that three
okay it's not like you bought a jet ski
or anything that's like 700 bucks a
treatment that's not too bad yeah yeah
yeah okay that's okay i did not know
that we were gonna talk about this um
oh my god can you say with certainty
that everyone in your family has seen
the sopranos
i haven't seen a soprano you haven't
seen this kid's trash
you kidding me it took you that long to
get to that
you made it you said your mom was
raccoon
in this [ __ ]
jacket i mean you're worried about the
[ __ ] sopranos
ah
if you're at the supermarket will you
get in the express lane with too many
items
i can't foresee you doing that
okay
what is your talent on somebody that did
playground narcan
those grapes have to go back how do you
guys feel about
cans of cat food like if i'm buying
10 cans of cat food hold on do you have
a cat i have two okay good
so
would you say 10 cans of cat food are 10
individual items listen i used to be yes
of course
oh wow but i don't pay attention i don't
give a [ __ ] about the express lane i'm
going in no matter what i got cat food's
different if it's the same thing because
if you can go like 10
if you can scan the one and go times ten
that's done oh okay i mean you're
looking for backup to go to the express
lane take as many cans of cat food as
you want okay yeah yeah it's okay that's
okay okay that's all right and you never
want to be that [ __ ] that's like god
are the people behind me thinking that
they are hot
let me be clear they are yeah but yeah i
don't know yeah [ __ ] them this is my
last question okay
what are the names of the cats
uh
oh boy this is gonna do it so
bungalow
which is just a name i made up because i
liked i like blue from jungle book and i
just liked the word bungalow and i put
them together and i didn't realize that
bung is slang for
like [ __ ] like bunghole
so that's that and then
mia
from pulp fiction
mia wallace
that's not that bad what was the name of
the dogs again growing up
sugar and rascal oh that'll do it
that'll do it thanks for tuning in
they're asking the one that bid the ass
do you know any of the names of the
raccoons that your mom named
oh i forget
i forget
but they were very raccoony
very raccoony very yeah
yeah buddy
100 trash yeah
wow
i got excited and then i realized what
you were saying and it's like because
you make it you make us feel like we won
or something like you did it no but then
you're like oh no you've been plagued
with it for the rest of your life
actually
generationally i would assume you're
going to inherit a shitload of beanie
babies yeah and that's the [ __ ]
raccoons
when they're going through the estate
sale those raccoons are going to claim
something i'm sure
squatters write something taking all my
mom's trophies
hey listen she can have the beanie
babies i'm taking the trophies i got to
split the storage unit with mr marbles
goddammit ladies and gentlemen kelsey
cook what do you got coming up what do
you want the folks to know we know
you're on tour right now you're doing
the hustler tour the hustler all over
yeah so um i'm at summit comedy club in
fort wayne indiana valentine's weekend
nice i'll be at the hartford funny bone
at the end of february syracuse funny
bone beginning of march acme comedy club
march 9th through 12th uh laugh boston
the weekend after that for wait no i'm
sorry am i in chicago i'm in chicago
okay chicago for uh saint patty's
weekend and then just it's like almost
every weekend for the next five months
and then others throughout the end of
the year so that's awesome
congratulations on 100 congratulations
i'm sure everybody out there knows you
kel's but if they don't guys you got to
go see her she's an absolute murderer
absolutely fantastic thanks thank you so
much for coming in and sitting down with
us being so open and honest that's great
the latex thing that's something i
forgot
about so latex and the raccoons man
yikes
um not to mention grandma's recipes were
pretty gross kippy what do you got what
was grandma's right the cat food oh
yeah ah
hey guys thanks for tuning in check out
our dates the link is in the description
for all of our live shows coming up
middle class famous tour baby uh and
then also at cameron comedy on all
social media check out the patreon the
whole nine yards is the special do
everything peace watch the smash we love
you we'll see you next week